to understand China's relationship with
Russia this is a good place to start the
remote northern city of haha just a
frozen River across from its neighbor
this place is a lot quieter than it used
to be money once spent by Russian
tourists has largely dried up but
everywhere you look there are signs of
the affinity
many of the products jiachang High cells
are from Russia they're good friends to
have he says his views are common around
here as is his take on the war that
Russia's not entirely to blame
and what do you think of the conflict in
Ukraine
[Music]
foreign
that opinion is encouraged in China the
real crimes of War painted over it says
it is neutral a peacemaker but signs of
support here say otherwise
like this the huge pipes transporting in
Russian gas China's buying much are what
was Once Sold to Europe
there are signs everywhere you look in
this place of just how vital this
relationship is to both sides indeed
from Russia China has been something of
a Lifeline but being no doubt this
friendship holds real value for China
too not just in terms of trade but also
as a crucial Ally and what it sees as a
reshaping of the world order its ever
deepening power struggle with the West
that's the bigger picture here the
standoff pushing two neighbors closer
they are linked by much more than just
this trade bridge between them
here we meet Slava a Russian truck
driver a cog in the wheels of this trade
he spoke with unusual frankness about
the position Russians are in
this what's your problem
foreign
this is still a sensitive subject we
were followed and watched as we filmed
China knows this visit speaks volumes it
is a careful line it is treading and its
number one interest is China Helena
Smith Sky News in heiha On the
china-russia Border